WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN TE
IF THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
ABORTION IS REMOVED, I
T OVERTURNS ROE.E THAT ON TH
BOOKS BEFORE ROE WAS DECIDED OR
HAVE PASSE-CIG BAC ROE IS
T'R OF
THE STATE AT THES
REPUBLICAN TATE REEVESF
GOVERNOR REEVES, THANK YOU FOR
JOING.F THE STATES
THAT H TRIGGER LAWSED INT WILLNS
AT STAKE, WITHEX FOR
CEST, IF ROE IOVERTURNED.
THIS WOULD REQRE
ATTORNEY GENER TO CERTIFY THAT
IF THE COURT RULES A M TRIGGER E
THOSO NARROWCU
ILLEGAL?
>> WELL, THANK YOU FOR HAVIN
MORNING, JAKE.'S DAYO ALL THNDN
INCLUDING THE FIRST F ISSIPPI, T
AFT OPINION,
A TI CONVERSATION AND BU YES, R
EFFECT.
IT DOES HA AN FOR
THE LIFE OF . ANT SAW BEFORE N
NOT TU END ABORTION.
N TO
SEEK OUT METHOT ARE NO
RESULTED IN MUTILATION OR EVEN
DEATH.
W,G TO UR STATE DEP3,500 ABORTI
HAS THE STATE DONE ANALYSIS OF
THOSE WOMEN AND GIRLS
ES,
HOW MANY UNWANTES
WILL RESULT INRED
USE THEY SEEK
HAVE YOU DONE AN ANALYSIS THAT .
AND I RELY IT.
AN TU IS
THIS.
AN DOING THE WORK OF WHAA PO
MISSISSIPPI WILL LOOK LIKE.
IN FACT, IF, I, THIS LOPINION I
ACCURATE, AND IF,
MAJORITY OTHESE
SUPREME COURT ARE
OVERTURN R MUST UNDERSTAND
THIS A GREAT
VEHICLER TO FOR THE
E END.
BEGINNING.
THE BEGINNING
G  IS NO ABOUTOR
K THAT
IS BEING DONE GOESN TWO
NUMBNEO
E CAN TOE ITER ON THOSE MS MAY B
INANPREGNANCIES.
E --
THISN THST
COUP O
LEGISLVIDE
RED MONE7
PREGNANCY RESOURCEEN
LOD ION OF
WE WSU WE GET
THOSE INDIVIALS AN
WOMED EXPECTANT MOTHERS TH
HELP TY  T ABOUT TH
CARE.
ABOUT OTHER RESOURCES THAT
AND THE SECOND OF BEING
PRE XTPRO-LIFE MOVEMEN ABOUT
ATG TO HELP E HAT MAYBE AR THEYO
GO TO FULL TERM, THAT THE MOMS
FOCUS ON MAKING ADOPTION EASIER
INISSISSIPPI.WE'RE FOCUPROVING
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.N THE
AND WE RECOGNIZE TDMSTT
SY
OVER $100 MILLIORO
TECHNOLOGY AT THNT OHUD
DID DO AN ANALYSIS.U YOU
CAN YOU TELL U
PRESIDENT ANALYSIS?
AGMISSISSIPPI,TATE OCONCLUDE AS
HOW MAF D
MUTILATED,HAEEORDI
WHAT DNASI?
>> WELL, I PREDICT
FOR YOOI TO
WHAT I CELL YOU IS WHAT
E N MISSISSIPPI IS WE'RE TRYINT
GO TO A FULL-TERM PREGNANCY IF
THAT'S A GREAT
WET TO ME SURE WEM THE RESOUNEE.
BUT IF
WANT TO KEURE WE HAVE PLANS
ONCE THEY'RE BORATOSTER
CARE, WE TALK ABOUT ADOPTIONS
AND OT, CREATING
FOREVER HOMES FOR
MISSISSIPPI, AS YOU THE HIGHEST
THE HIES
POVERTY IN THENI HAS N
PAID.
THE LEGISLATURE INIPPI ST RECTEN
COVERAGE.
YOUR FOSTER M IS ALSO
THE EC A LONG-RUNNING
FEDERAL LAWSUIT  ISE.
YOU AND HA
CONV
I HEAR
TORT MOTHERS AND BUT YOU'VEEEN
T NOW TNT S
BASED ON THE TCK RECORD OF THE
STATE OFSIIP
ANY OF THESE GIRLS O
BELIEVE YOU?
>> WELL, LS I'VE TOLD YOU RE AN
ELECTED GOVERNORMYY FIRST AL A
I WAS VERY C TI BELIEVE
BUT R .IDE OUR PROBLEMS
AVE LONGRY OF POOR  OUTCOMES DU
PART TREG EVERON
BEFORE YOU TK T THINGSOU TALG
LADIES, THE BEST TE CAN DO
R THEM IVIOVE EDATWE'V EXTREMEL
PROVIDE WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITIES,
JOBS.
BUT TO DO THATE
IMPROVE THQUHEIR
SKILLS.
WE AS A STATE AR
HEAVILY IN THAT.
OU'RE RIGHT.
GOT A NUMBERS OF
POOR OUTCOMES.
WE'RE WORKY SINGLE
TO IROVE TD I THINK YOU'LL IFIC
ON THE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOME FRONT
IN MSSR  T
ARO, THEP BACK LAWT ED I20 HAS .
SO, ASSUMING TOURTRNS RO STATE
OF MISSISSIPPI WILL FORCE RL
AND WOMEN WHO AR
INCEST T
TO TER
WHY THATE YOUR LAWG TO BE THE B
IT.SISSIPPI LEGISL
WIYOU, JAKE,S SORT SPEAKS  HOW E
COME ON THIS IUEBUT IN007
WHEN THE T WAS PUT IN ACE, WE HA
DEMOCRAT CHAIRMAN OF T PUBLIC
HEALTH COMMITTEE IN
MIUSE OFPRUTT
FORCE GIRLS WHO ARE VICT O CARR
TOS YOKNOWJAKE, OV% OF ALLE ELE
1%.
IF THAN THE FUTURE ABOUTTENTIAL-
>> THIS IS YOUR LAW.HE TRIGGER
CERTAINLY DO THAT.
THE REALITY IS, AIAFFECTS LESS
ABORTIONS INRI O
LAW OF MISSISSIPPI.G TO BE T
SK,  A
FETUS THAT SERIOUSR FATA
WILL NOT
USWOHE STATE OPP THOSE
RLS AN
HETOAR T
ARE YOU GOING TO FORCE THEL, JA.
THAT YOU'RE DEALING IN
OVONS.THE REASON FORECAUSE T
WHEN YOUALK TONS
REGARDLESSF WHAT THE POLLING
SAYSITURNING
OF AMERICANS THAABORTIONMERICA .
ORTIONE
EXE ST ON YOU KNOWHA I
DID NOT JAKE, EVEN
ROE, EVEN IF T DECIDED MISS